[Música]
[Aplausos]
hablar de educación ha sido uno de los
temas a nivel mundial de los últimos
años y vemos como los países quieren
cambiar y mejorar todos los modelos
educativos vemos también las escuelas
los retos un poquito de políticas
públicas que se quieren mejorar y
raramente en todo este proceso se habla
del actor principal de la educación
el alumno hablar del alumno hablar de su
corazón de sus emociones de qué quiere
creo que se ha dejado de lado y queremos
cambiar la educación a través de
programas a través de mejorar las
instituciones educativas
antes de empezar quiero hacer una
reflexión de cuántas horas estamos en la
escuela si tuvimos la oportunidad de ir
al preescolar la primaria de la
secundaria a la prepa a la universidad
estuvimos ahí aproximadamente 2400 horas
en preescolar 6000 en primaria etcétera
etcétera finalmente nos sumó un
aproximado de 19 mil 560 horas dentro
del aula es decir ochocientos quince
días
después de diecinueve mil quinientos
sesenta horas tenemos un título y vamos
a trabajar y ahí es donde empieza a ver
una diferencia muy interesante que yo
aprendí estando en un organismo
empresarial lo estático un poquito de mi
vida que he estado muchos años en el
sector académico en la escuela de nivel
básico he conocido la dinámica entre
directivos entre docentes padres de
familia y alumnos también he conocido la
relación con el sistema educativo
inspectores escolares secretarios de
educación
hasta ahí todo va muy bien mientras los
alumnos vayan cumpliendo con los planes
y programas en el mejor de los casos
cada uno de los muchachos saque vías en
todas sus materias pero después tuve una
oportunidad de estar en un organismo
empresarial en la comisión de educación
y entonces las cosas empezaron a cambiar
cuando llegas a la presidencia de una
comisión de educación de un organismo
empresarial
los empresarios te preguntan por qué la
educación está tan mal
y no es que no cumplan con los planes y
programas los alumnos sino que hay un
espacio entre lo académico y entre lo
que se requiere en la vida productiva
empresarial como colaborador como
empleado o como emprendedor inclusive y
ese espacio que hay entre la academia y
entre la empresa hay un vacío que sólo
una persona lo puede llenar no lo puede
llenar ni la escuela ni lo puede llenar
la empresa eso solo pues lo puede llenar
el mismo alumno y para ello pues nos
pusimos a estudiar a revisar a platicar
con todos los actores del tema educativo
y encontramos que hay una escalera que
le saltan peldaños esta escalera le
llamamos escalera formativa como pueden
ver en la imagen tenemos algunos
peldaños que están vacíos y queremos
brincar de la escuela básica incluyendo
la preparatoria a la universidad dejando
espacios intermedios los cuales así como
está la imagen nos invitan a tropezarnos
oa caernos
de qué trata esta escalera formativa en
el primero primero de los escalones
tenemos que preguntarle al alumno desde
pequeño cuál es tu sueño
creo que los sistemas educativos no se
están preocupando por el corazón por el
alma por por lo que quiere cada uno de
los jóvenes cuál es su sueño que quiere
ser qué quieres hacer de grande y este
sueño por más chusco que sea si quieren
ser superhéroes o quieren ser el bombero
quiere ser astronauta son importantes
pero importante no nada más escucharlo y
dejarlo y si no hay que anotar lo que es
el sueño del niño
este sueño es la base para definir
posteriormente el propósito de vida
entre el sueño y la definición del
propósito de vida tenemos que
asegurarnos que se aproveche la
educación básica que es saber leer y
escribir aunque se escuche muy sencillo
para muchos de nosotros después de esas
10 y 3.560 horas muchos empresarios se
han quejado de que las personas con su
título en la mano no saben escribir
correctamente a nivel profesional
entonces entre el sueño y la definición
del propósito hay que asegurarnos que
pasen el nivel básico de manera correcta
que sepan leer y escribir adecuadamente
y todas las otras asignaturas básicas
pero a la hora de definir el propósito
de vida es un tema súper interesante
cómo lo vamos a definir hay que pensar
en un problema común en un problema
social en un problema mundial hay que
pensar en grande tenemos que decirle a
nuestros estudiantes a nuestros hijos a
nuestros alumnos qué quieres resolver
del mundo
y a partir de ahí vamos a definir un
propósito con 20 palabras o menos muy
sencillo para poder decir hasta que
quiero llegar que sea inalcanzable que
sea algo grande algo grandioso para que
después con las metas y con los
objetivos vayamos queriendo alcanzar
está este propósito de vida
una vez que definamos el propósito de
vida y ya vamos ya vamos aprovechando
cada cosa que vemos en la escuela ya le
encontramos sentido a la escuela y eso
lo he comprobado con jóvenes y con
maestros que así me lo han hecho saber
pero hay algo todavía más importante el
aprendizaje empírico también lo hemos
olvidado
hemos nos hemos dedicado a decirle a
nuestros niños para eso vas a la escuela
no trabajes para eso vas a la escuela no
tienes que entretenerte haciendo otras
cosas no tienes por qué usar el martillo
ni el taladro ni iniciar otra otra cosa
porque para eso vas a la escuela y vamos
a la escuela y de repente no sabemos
exactamente para que el aprendizaje
empírico también he puesto bastantes
ejemplos al respecto
hay por ahí un señor panadero tal vez
que de meter un pan al horno hace más de
50 años hoy podrá tener la panadería más
grande del mundo y cuando lo planteo
esto con los jóvenes se espanta decir
cómo es un panadero puede ser un gran
empresario por supuesto pero la
habilidad es ser panadero por poner un
solo ejemplo de muchos otros por eso no
tenemos que dejar de lado todas estas
habilidades tradicionales la carpintería
la plomería el ser herrero el saber
hacer las cosas yo le pregunto a los
jóvenes 18 años terminando su
bachillerato que sabes hacer y muchos de
ellos quedan fríos seguir a la escuela
pero nadie te va a contratar por ser
experto general de escuela que van a
contratar por tener habilidades técnicas
y por supuesto las habilidades blandas y
en el mismo sentido también tenemos a
nuestro alcance un mundo impresionante
de aprendizajes en línea pero qué pasa
con este mundo inmenso de aprendizajes
que podemos tener en la red si no
tenemos un propósito de vida cuál de
todos estos miles y millones de
aprendizajes que podemos tener en línea
vamos a escoger si no tenemos un
propósito de vida si no tenemos un sueño
al cual estamos persiguiendo si lo que
estamos haciendo sólo es ir a la escuela
a cumplir con lo que nos dicen sacar
días y entonces todos nos feliciten
necesitamos tener ese sueño ese
propósito de vida empezar a tener
nuestros aprendizajes empíricos por
supuesto y aprovechar lo que nos da la
red del día de hoy cualquier cosa que
queramos aprender en por lo menos máximo
cinco minutos encontramos un curso desde
un youtube un videotutorial hasta un
curso formal en una universidad global
entonces estamos dejando fuera estos
elementos de nuestra escalera formativa
y así es como queremos que quede nuestra
escalera formativa empecemos el primer
peldaño sólido con un sueño cuál es tu
sueño
si quieres hacer que suene hacer segundo
peldaño la formación básica no olvidemos
que tenemos que fortalecer cada una de
las herramientas que nos dan como saber
leer y escribir y lo insisto mucho
porque si no lo practicamos de manera
formal no nos sirve de mucho todas las
clases que tenemos así me lo han hecho
saber ya con la experiencia muchos
empresarios
en el tercer escalón hay que ser el
propósito de vida hay que escribirlo hay
que ponerle metas y objetivos para
alcanzar ese propósito de vida puede
variar cuántas veces quieran no tienen
que casarse con un propósito de vida y
los objetivos y las metas las va a ir
alcanzando y cumpliendo y vas a poner
más y más y más y este trabajo es de
casas de papás de maestros de todos
el aprendizaje empírico también lo
comentábamos de aprendizaje online y
estamos listos posiblemente para entrar
a una carrera técnica lo pongo en primer
lugar y el segundo una carrera
universitaria creo que hemos caído en la
trampa de decir vamos corriendo hasta la
universidad estemos o no estemos
preparados creo que vale más la pena
estudiar una carrera técnica fortalecer
tu oficio dedicarte a algo y por qué no
en un momento ir a la universidad si
escuchan se espantan algunos cuando se
espera te como no tienen que irse
estudiando corriendo no tienen que
hacerlo cuando estén suficientemente
maduros y finalmente alcanzar el
proyecto personal de vida que quieran un
proyecto productivo ser emprendedores
ser colaboradores de una empresa por
supuesto está excelente pero ya
alcanzando y alcanzando su propio
propósito de vida una aclaración que hay
que hacerle a muchos muchos jóvenes
el plan de estudios no es tu plan de
vida muchas veces preguntas cuál es tu
plan de vida puedes estudiar
arquitectura
cuál es tu plan a quién le vas a mejorar
la vida quién le vas a mejorar el mundo
a través de tu estudio en arquitectura
pues necesitamos cambiar un poquito el
estudiar un plan de estudios insisto no
es un plan de vida para cada una de las
personas hay que diferenciarlo ese es un
peldaño estudiar una carrera es un
peldaño para alcanzar un propósito de
vida finalmente lo que hay que inculcar
más en todos nuestros chicos en todos
nuestros estudiantes que amen todo lo
que hagan hay que si vemos que nuestros
hijos van bajo protesta silenciosa a la
escuela hay que inculcarles el amor por
lo que hace el amor en cada momento el
amor en cada meta que vayan alcanzando
el amor en cada objetivo y algo bien
importante el amor a cada fracaso que
vayan teniendo desafortunadamente en
nuestra cultura nos han puesto el
fracaso como algo malo el fracaso como
algo que es de gente que está derrotada
y no por el contrario si vemos los
éxitos globales los grandes
emprendimientos a nivel global
están construidos de puros fracasos el
primer fracaso el segundo el tercero el
cuarto el quinto el sexto pero de una
persistencia de un aprendizaje de cada
uno de esos fracasos para llegar
finalmente a lograr un objetivo
específico a alcanzar hoy estar
alcanzando su propósito de vida
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]